[Musique]
bonjour c'est the blind artiviste
créateur du graffiti pour aveugles
aujourd'hui je vais venir vous je viens
vous parler pour parler du de ma
pratique qui est spécifique
le graffiti pour aveugles donc tout
commence dans les années 2000 lors d'une
sortie scolaire en terminale à la
comment à saint paul de vence dans un
musée qui s'appelle la fondation mail je
suis donc avec mes collègues
hop on regarde les différentes toiles et
une toile m'intrigue m'excite je trouve
ça étrange cette ses traits de peinture
jeux je vois du relief et là je m'amuse
à la touche et tout d'un coup la sécu
arrive me met la main sur l'épaule et me
dit monsieur s'il vous plaît vous n'avez
pas le droit de toucher c'est interdit
vous êtes obligé de sortir c'est les
règles
donc je me vois tout seul dehors dans le
jardin du musée où il ya des oeuvres de
miro comme celle que j'ai je venais de
touché et donc là bas je me sens un peu
triste parce que j'étais content de
découvrir différents artistes on va voir
les toiles en vrai est donc seul
j'attends mes collègues
quelques années plus tard je découvre le
graffiti je commence à peindre des murs
des stores d'être un jus avec plein de
collègues je fais partie de différentes
équipes qu'on appelle des crew et
suite à une cession graffitis sur le
périph nantes est un copain vient me
dire ce qu'on a fait là c'est énorme
c'est des grosses lettres en capital ça
va être vu par tout le monde moi tout de
suite je lui dis bah non pour les
aveugles
en rentrant chez moi je me dis mais il
ya un truc faire du graffiti qui est un
art visuel pour les aveugles c'est comme
faire de la musique pour les sourds il
ya moyen d'être différent avoir une
certaine singularité est à la fois
rendre accessible le graffiti aux
personnes déficientes visuelles et donc
suite à ce constat je m'intéresse aux
systèmes d'écriture tactile qui est le
braille et donc que je découvre tout ce
ce nouvel et ce nouvel univers dont
j'essaie de comprendre les différentes
combinaisons
donc chaque lettre est composé de six
points sur une cellule il y a six points
et dans ces six points il ya une
combinaison de différents points donc
par exemple elle
il va avoir les trois points
du côté gauche le à ce sera que la
combinaison d'un point donc là je
découvre donc cet univers qui est à la
fois un probable de découvrir le bain
comment ils agissent comment ils
décrivent comment ils lisent et donc ils
lisent avec les deux premières phalanges
ils écrivent avec soin d perkins donc
des machines à écrire en braille ou des
tablettes dans laquelle on vient écrire
de droite à gauche
et quand on retourne la feuille on lit
de gauche à droite et donc là je lui ai
dit mais là c'est énorme j'ai trouvé
quelque chose sachant que c'est un code
et je trouvais ça intéressant de
comparer le tag et l'art contemporain
parce que ces deux univers ont besoin
d'une grille de lecture là je me suis
dit voilà je vais utiliser le braille et
là il faudra vraiment comprendre et
connaître
alphabet et donc là je décide de partir
dans la rue pour le rendre accessible et
visible et donc je pars un amour du
risque et de l'adrénaline je décide de
briser les frontières et de casser les
codes établis et donc mon premier
braille
c'est assez simple jeu j'ai écrit ne pas
toucher sur le sur le musée des
beaux-arts de nantes tête en référence
au fait que je m'étais fait virer du
musée de la fondation mail et donc voilà
les mon premier braille et écrit des
aveugles par la suite j'apprends que des
aveugles sont venus touchée on rigolait
de de cette blague
peut-être potache mais en tout cas
importante pour moi parce que dans les
musées
on n'a pas le droit de toucher le
braille est fait pour toucher et donc je
trouvais ça assez drôle décrire cette
phrase là et donc me voilà parti à
découvrir différentes villes différents
endroits parce que pour moi
les lieux sont très importants par
exemple je vais aller avec mon pochoir
donc qui est plein de trous où je viens
qu'acheter avec du scotch les trous que
j'ai besoin pour faire mes repères sur
les murs par la suite je viens prendre
des demi sphère en plâtre que je viens
collet est par exemple j'ai fait j'ai
écrit une phrase en dessous la tipp pour
palais de justice
j'ai écrit en braille pas vu pas pris
peut-être en référence à mon passé
judiciaire aimé mais mes petits ennuis
avec la justice grâce bas à cause du
graffiti et non grâce au graffiti est
donc un petit clin d'oeil comme ça à la
justice qui est des fois parfois et qui
est des foi aveugle et là je commence à
partir en interne avec mes collègues
donc l'interrail c'est des billets de
trains qui sont ouverts pour voyager
pendant un mois
et donc nous voilà partis dans
différentes villes on a commencé par
paris ou face à la tour eiffel j'ai
écrit vus et revus au palais
tokyo j'ai écrit la retouche point
d'interrogation
j'ai toujours été aussi intéressés par
des lieux improbables comme sur cette
photo les catacombes où on rentre par
des trappes
on a de l'eau des fois jusqu'au torse on
est dans le noir et en fait je trouvais
ça intéressant parce qu'un collègue
m'avait dit un jour il y a aussi des
personnes malvoyantes et aveugles qui
viennent dans les catacombes et je me
dis c'est énorme je vais aller faire un
braai dedans on n'y voit rien et je vais
écrire broyer du noir
peut-être une personne aveugle l'a déjà
à lui axé ma ou pas mais en tout cas
pour la pour l'expérience je trouvais ça
important
j'adore aussi aller dans les tunnels de
métro
c'est un peu retour aux sources du
graffiti ce que je continue ou graffitis
depuis déjà ça fait déjà depuis une
vingtaine d'années que je fais du
graffiti et donc je m'amuse à aller dans
le métro pour collecter des sons à les
coller du braille et surtout pour le
souvenir et l'expérience par la suite
donc quand on interroge de continuer je
vais au en chez nos amis les belges à
bruxelles ou là par exemple je viens
coller du du braille sur la bourse de
bruxelles où j'écris la bourse ou la vue
ça se passe pas comme j'avais prévu la
police arrive sur la voiture de la
police il ya une caméra
donc je me dis je suis filmé autant y
aller à fond
autant il est allé au bluff autant
mettre une disquette comme on dit dans
le jargon du graffiti et donc que la
police me dis mais qu'est ce que vous
faites
bah je viens de là bas je viens avec
autorisation de la mairie mais comme je
suis tête en l'air par rapport à mon
travail j'ai oublié l'autorisation je
suis là pour faire une signalétique pour
aveugles et donc il me faut un bon s
écrit quoi la bourse ou la labour la
bourse où la vue est là donc les les
commandes et les policiers commencent à
se marrer ils font mal ah ouais 1500
élèves comment amédée la première puis
dès la première plus ça s'en va il n'y
aura pas une seule trace vous inquiétez
pas il était super content de mon
initiative ils m'ont même demandé si je
pouvais leur donner une demi-sphère je
leur ai donné une demi-sphère ils sont
partis avec ce cadeau tout ça bien sûr
été faits illégalement par la suite j'ai
bougé un peu partout donc en europe en
russie
dandy dans plein d'autres pays et je me
dis moi je vais aller chez les ch et les
américains et donc me voilà en
californie en road trip
donc je m'amuse à faire une cabane en un
peu à l'image des cabanes convoi dans
alerte à malibu que je suis là je suis
né dans les années 80 donc on a regardé
c'était serré avec mes frangins et je
voulais absolument faire une cabane de
plage avec les les sauveteurs en mer et
donc sur la cabane j'ai écrit à perte de
vue
par la suite j'ai donc continué mon mon
périple en en camion et j'ai été dans la
death valley donc un désert il fait une
chaleur de dingue
pourtant on est au mois de février et là
je viens coller une
du braille sur sur une grosse citerne
abandonné donc un paysage de dingo et là
le tout d'un coup il ya un shérif qui
arrive qui vient gros dérapage main sur
le gun et là tout de suite je lève les
mains l'habitude de me faire serrer dans
le graffiti et il commença à bien mais
qu'est ce que vous faites ici c'est un
patrimoine cinématographique d'hollywood
tout de suite dans ma tête je me dis je
suis je suis je suis dans de beaux draps
je suis clairement dans la merde et là
et commence on commence à discuter ils
voient que c'est du braille et je lui
dis bah voilà ça va partir dès la
première pluie je me dis que ça va
passer comme avec les belges mais là on
est dans l'adn valais hélas le shérif me
dis ici il ne pleut jamais et là je suis
là là là ça va pas être femme cette
affaire et là le gars se détend et me
dit ah je parle un peu français avec son
action un peu redneck bien bien
américain de la déesse valais est le
gars me dire c'est marrant j'ai fait les
beaux-arts de paris là j'hallucine et
ont donc on commence à discuter
j'ai fini par me prendre en photo avec
lui la main sur l'épaule et lui la main
sur le gun est donc tout ça toutes ces
photos on les retrouvera dans un livre
que je suis en train de créer avec une
amie avec deux amis où on verra mais mes
15 ans de voyages dans le monde donc
c'est toute une aventure de faire un
livre à la fois pour les aveugles et à
la fois pour les voyants et à la fois
pour les malvoyants parce que ce livre
sera composé de bright sera composé
d'une typographie adapté qui s'appelle
lucioles et il y aura aussi un cd avec
une trappe l'audiodescription donc tout
mon livre comme la base de mon travail
il y aura un partage à la fois les
voyants pourront comprendre leur parti
les aveugles pourront comprendre mal à
leur est en fait le partage des deux
points de vue donnera l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de la compréhension de mon
travail donc je vous invite à aller voir
mes différents réseaux sociaux pour
découvrir mon travail parce que ça fait
donc depuis 2004 que je fais du graffiti
pour aveugles et j'ai un travail à la
fois dans la rue est à la fois en
festival et en atelier donc voilà
j'espère que ça vous a plu
et à bientôt toucher l'art et l'art vous
touchera
[Musique]